so it was felt sandy Stewie and mace
burry capital wouldn't proceed with her
bed without you but they have gone
public with a bear hug and you could
stop it okay yeah my dad wants me to do
it the first episode of the second
season it follows on like 36 48 hours
after after the events of the first
season and we were interested what does
it how does it feel to wake up after
what
Kendall's gone through what does his
face look like was his body looked like
what's he gonna say to people now candle
tell us what happened why did you get
involved why did you back out the longer
the short of it is I saw their plan and
my dad's plan was better the interest of
the show is seeing these people go
through their stuff and they go through
quite a bit of stuff ladies and
gentlemen the first thing my
son's ever done right in his life in the
scene where Logan talks about the future
of the company we need to discuss this
bear hug stick or so people have to
decide whether they think he is saying
the table for the discussion he has with
his kids in a frank way or if he's
loading the dice please I want you to
speak freely anything you say can and
will be used against you in a court of
law
like come on we're all pals yeah that's
how I didn't have it out I love
money but I'm really scared of you Logan
wants a family legacy when he looks at
Roman I don't think he sees it there
tomorrow and his son has both betrayed
him and also been in circumstances which
make him seem like not a good candidate
right now and a Connor I think he would
laugh about it so she feels like well
that's what he's gonna do right it
seemed obvious to us what I've decided
I'd like to do is to formally ask you to
come in they'll be the next chief
executive of this club
it nearly made me cry seeing chip sort
of finally say what she has always
wanted I think there's some things in
life that you don't almost even know you
want until you say it and then it can be
quite powerful and overwhelming the
acceptance way you want to do it yes
all right yes
[Music]
you